bill Livingston here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you bill hello I'm there
how are you bill it's rich I'm fine
well thank you thank you for for joining
how do things stand right now between
LeBron James and the Cleveland Cavaliers
best you can tell well I've always
thought that I've never privy to his few
people are privy to his innermost
thoughts I've always thought he was
going to leave and I and I wouldn't feel
at all like I did the first time because
of bringing a championship and because
he's a different guy you know I've come
to really respect and admire him and and
I was very hard on him when he left
you know so his social conscience great
amount of charity role to Akron people
you know the disadvantage is funding at
college education is just a lot of
things a very almost a model citizen
that having said I don't see a
championship coming anytime soon with
the way this team is constructed you
know I don't know whether there's really
a good landing spot for him right now
because the Lakers are you know they're
they weren't a good team and courtly
certainly if they got Kawhi in him they
they probably would be but I don't see a
good fit with Philadelphia I don't think
he really wants to live leave the East
because it's always still even with the
rise of Philadelphia and Boston it's
it's going to be an easier place to get
to the finals in the West so I guess
then it's possible that he probably
would stay here that's what I'm saying
he reads those tea leaves best you said
there bill yeah that that the East is a
better and easier path and then it is
the West but staying put it still is a
difficult roast know that you're in
right so I just don't get the you know I
I've always felt like the son of MVP
award
I know they got to do something to
distinguish the 82 game grind but you
know I would you rather have James
Harden or LeBron James come on and you
know this team would might have finished
in the damn Gigli without LeBron and
they they want
going to the finals I was I totally
disagree with that it would be people oh
but I felt that way several times so
what do you think the Cavs are doing
right now what can you tell us the best
do they had a different owner for one
thing I know LeBron and he don't get
along at all and it's just wide gulf on
all sorts of issues you know from from
politics to the way LeBron was treated
last time and I don't know whether they
ever kissed and really made up for that
I think it was a wider thing that he
wanted to do something for the Northeast
Ohio area and you know letting David
Griffith walk and and and letting Kyrie
walk he wanted to he wanted them to
bring Kyrie to training camp and he was
convinced he could work that out now I
don't believe that because I think
Irving was consumed by jealousy and a
great player that he is but offensively
certainly but but you know he I think he
would have had this knee operation then
that was what he was threatening if you
don't let me go I'm gonna have I'm gonna
have knee surgery now and he just wanted
out and but you know that's the way
LeBron felt about it at the time I think
you'd that bothered him a lot and of
course they got you know a bag of magic
means for for Kyrie at first before they
revamped the team I mean they got a
diminutive guard who was a terrible fit
with LeBron because he was had to had
the ball you know Isiah Thomas was the
same type of ball dominant guy in jeans
not LeBron James nobody else is so I
guess what he wasn't found I mean you
know he's sure they're player than he
shows what son cracked up let's unpack
that a little bit then bill then why did
Cutler you know I guess if had to use
the few good men phrase if Santiago is
ordered not to be touched and LeBron
doesn't want Kyrie to be touched then
why was he touched with two years left
on his deal bill I've never understood
that I've I think they I think they
thought the draft pick was good well I
know they thought the draft pick was
something they really wanted they hadn't
had their own pick I think since 2018 or
maybe it was I mean 2015 or something
like that I well yeah they might have
even been when they traded Mitch Andrew
Wiggins was their first lottery you
there last time the
good draft pick but you know I didn't
turn it it didn't turn out as good as
they had thought this they've been
insanely lucky lucky in the in the
lottery of course they should have taken
over the depot but he wasn't player that
that's right yes now but you know they
got Kyrie and LeBron and they got they
got Wiggins who was the ammunition to be
able to make a debate to be able to make
a trade for Kevin Love well I guess I
guess in a way bill that this is all
spilt milk right now although it is part
and parcel of the roster that might
cause LeBron to just say I'm out so what
what what decision even is it possible
that he opts in and asks for a
sign-and-trade that he's worked out on
his own bill I mean what are you hearing
about what the answer thinking on he
would have the power he would have he
would be the guy who could do that no I
don't think that would happen i I think
he's I you know I I think he feels
really torn and it's nothing new I mean
I don't think he wants to uproot his
family I think he feels a lot of loyalty
to the city when he leaped up on the
scores table twice after hitting the
buzzer beating shots in the playoffs
this year after after the first time he
said these people know me they've
watched me play since I was in high
school I think it means a lot to him but
I think it's a head versus heart you
know duality working our conflict there
and I just really don't see him staying
but I wouldn't fall over and shock if he
did you know I really nobody really
knows what he's thinking he he keeps his
counsel very tight bill Livingston of
the Cleveland Plain Dealer joining me
here on the show and let's dig a little
bit more into the Dan Gilbert
relationship that this is because we saw
how they had they had a moment I wasn't
even a moment when he was strolling to
the podium after the Eastern Conference
Finals victory he barely even slapped a
man's hand I mean and we all were
reading into that that there's there's
something there to read into bill for
real
well they he doesn't like her respect
Daniel but I think that's obvious he he
tried to put it she tried to make a
relationship work I don't think the fact
that he is LeBron is such a
outspoken critic of Trump and Gilbert is
a guy who I think gave 750 thousand
dollars or something like that I've seen
to Trump's campaign and and popped up
popped up at the White House when the
Cubs were being honored that's right
which was you know there's a little not
the best optics here in Cleveland since
they had beaten the Indians in the World
Series but you know I mean there's I
just think there's economic golf and
political golf and personality gulf
between the two of them Gilbert's very
popular owner here in town because they
want a championship and because he has
spent the money and that's been the
historic drawback of Cleveland owners
it's you know for the Indians and were
able to be a big market team for a while
because in a new ballpark but not not
once the cable revenues became the
determining factor and you know Modell
was living hand-to-mouth for a long time
with the Browns who have just been a
joke for 20 years so you know yeah it
could be ownership - it could could get
it again it could be the Quietus of this
relationship it's been a great four year
run though I'm you know I'm gonna draw a
parallel in a column I'm having it
coming out soon that everybody remembers
the Browns as being this dominant great
team in the 50s well that was in the a
AFC and they they did win they did win
four championships in the NFL but they
were they were one in three against the
Detroit Lions in the 50s who are the
Cavs one and three against their Golden
State Warriors you know greatness is how
you look at it you know you can look at
greatness a lot of ways just getting to
the finals
I guess eight or nine times now for him
and and and leading this Cavs team
against it 73 win team and winning two
of the last three winning all the last
three and two of them out there
you know that's the greatest thing I
think I've ever covered because three of
the greatest plays in Cleveland sports
history all happened the last two two
and a half three minutes of the game -
that's right it's so last one for you
Bill again this story that's coming out
on ESPN saying how the Lakers are
feeling pressure to acquire Kawhi
Leonard because that's their best shot
at getting LeBron right now with Paul
George rumor
to be staying put where he is in
Oklahoma City is there anything you
think the Cavs can do in the next 48
hours to keep LeBron James no I don't
think they have the ammunition once they
didn't get a once they didn't get a
better bounce of the lottery balls this
year
why Leonard I think has some questions
about him that make carrier rays look
kind of paltry right now actually
whatever you know San Antonio is a model
organization he couldn't get along with
them bill appreciate the time all right
thanks again you bet that's Bill
Livingstone of the Plain Dealer there in
Cleveland with the boots on the ground
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience